hey 42 here the world is changing
technology is advancing and automation
is fast taking over our lives and our
workplaces in the 19th century the
Industrial Revolution came crashing into
existence and within a few short years
thousands of manual labor jobs were
replaced by machines
then came the robots and every factory
in every industry started to replace
production line staff with automated
robots that do the same job better
faster and cheaper but if you think that
the biggest changes in jobs have already
happened then you've got a big surprise
coming your way because the future is
about to be turned on its head and you
won't believe what is going to happen to
virtually every job you know that's
right the robots are coming some of them
are already here now they're after your
job if you've already watched my video
on artificial intelligence then you'll
already know just how powerful AI is and
how quickly it is becoming but before
true AI gets here we have another
challenge to face potential mass
unemployment if you fought that complex
jobs like bartending cooking and also
intelligent jobs such as doctors and
lawyers can't possibly be replaced by
robots then let me show you how you're
so wrong and how machines are already
doing these jobs today not in ten years
but right now but first we need to
dispel a common myth what is that myth
that the more we use robotics and
computer software to automate our
industries the fewer jobs that there are
for real humans
what if I told you that it's actually
the complete opposite yes
it is true that the Industrial
Revolution destroyed a lot of jobs many
repetitive tasks could be easily
replaced by steam-driven and later
electric machines but for every job that
was destroyed more than one new job was
created
what's more the new jobs that work
were less repetitive more fulfilling and
on average paid a higher wage examples
of new jobs were engineers to maintain
the new factory machines and designers
to create them since they were paying
less for factory staff more of
businesses monies could be put into
hiring other stuff such as salesman
admin staff accountants and many many
others but if so many new hire paid jobs
were created when the machines arrived
how come living standards was so low
well truth is they weren't it's easy to
picture the Industrial Revolution with
poverty-stricken families being worked
to the bone the cotton mills are down
the mines for a few shillings per week
some people imagine the Industrial
Revolution as a period of gross
capitalist greed where a few got
extremely wealthy whilst the rest was
only group poorer and hungrier but this
simply isn't true sure there were some
extreme cases during these times human
rights laws hadn't been created yet that
neither had minimum wages or minimum
working gauges and sure there are many
stories of very young children doing
horrendously arduous and dangerous jobs
either at the mills or in the pits but
when we look at the actual statistics
everything points to the Industrial
Revolution actually bringing a happier
healthier and longer life to the
majority of families in the Western
world when we look at the UK the
statistics show that blue-collar wages
doubled between 1810 and 1850 and across
the country the average wage increased
from 11 pound per capita in 1780 to 28
pound per capita in 1860 and the icing
on the industrial cake was that the
lower cost of production created by the
arrival of the machines meant that the
prices of pretty much everything that
people bought from food to clothes were
significantly reduced these factors
created a much higher standard of living
for most families and with this came the
advent and growth of the middle class
this is not hyperbole the statistics
reflect this in England during the
Industrial Revolution the average
family's consumption of expensive foods
such as meats sugar tea and beer
increased dramatically and amazingly so
did the consumption of very expensive
foreign imports such as cocoa coffee
rice and tobacco before the Industrial
Revolution only the very wealthy
upper-class would have been able to
consume such luxurious items
astonishingly if you look at the average
Englishman's diet in 1850 it's pretty
much the same diet that most of us still
eat today - all look processed food of
course in 1850 the average weekly diet
was 140 grams of butter 850 grams of
meat 1.6 kilograms of potatoes and 450
grams of fruit and vegetables so then it
seems contrary to popular belief as a
result of capitalism and the invention
of machines and Industry working-class
families ate more and better food they
wore better clothes and they enjoyed
higher wages and there is absolutely no
doubt that if the Industrial Revolution
hadn't have happened the entire
developed world wouldn't live such a
cushy lifestyle as we do today
nowhere near without the Industrial
Revolution and the machines that caused
it you can forget all the technology
luxuries and comforts that you enjoy
each and every day experts say that what
is coming over the next five to ten
years will be the next Industrial
Revolution but this time
we'll be the intelligence revolution or
the robot revolution if you like because
it sounds a bit cooler but the big
question is will things turn out for the
better like they did last time around or
will things end up much much worse if
history is to be repeated then the
entrance of robots in the workplace
should improve our lives significantly
but the problem is things are so very
different this time around and it may
just be one of the most terrifying
transitional periods in the history of
the human race why are things so
different well during the Industrial
Revolution it was really easy for people
to keep up with the fast moving pace of
the new technology it only took a few
weeks to take a manual laborer and train
them to become a machinist giving them a
whole new job for the new age they found
themselves in in fact there hasn't just
been one Industrial Revolution there
have already been three
the first was mechanization with the
invention of steam power and the
mechanical Lu the second revolution was
mass production introducing the assembly
line and electricity
the third was automation utilizing the
power of computers and software but the
fourth revolution that has already begun
today is it that of a automated cars
drones smart robotics and 3d printing
the problem with this revolution is that
technology is going to move so fast that
it will move faster than we can chase it
and the vast majority of the workers
today are sadly going to get left behind
here's an interesting fact for you
during the entire history of the modern
world from the 1600s until today only
one job has been completely replaced by
technology
no I'm not joking just what and that job
is elevator operators every other job
has just had to adjust in some way or
over when the ATM was invented it was
thought that within a few years
every bank teller would be out of a job
but of course they weren't they just
shifted into a new more sales orientated
role advising people on the need
products that's it could apparently
enhanced their lives like credit cards
and loans but this time it's so so
different and there will be far more
than one job that will be entirely
replaced how do we know this for certain
because it's already happening right now
do you know what else is happening right
now
an incredible offer at Skillshare
Skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of classes in
design business technology and so much
more
Premium Membership gives you unlimited
access to high-quality classes on must
know topics so you can improve your
skills unlock new opportunities and just
do the work you love jobs that can't and
won't be replaced by robots will be
those that involve a high degree of
creativity such as the arts videography
and photography human creativity is just
too unique an attribute to be emulated
by robots so why don't you scrub up on
your creative skills like photo editing
I highly recommend the skill share
course edit like a pro Photoshop for
photographers it will teach you
everything you need to know to edit
photographs to the same standards as
world-class professionals what I really
like about skill share is that it's just
so affordable an annual subscription is
less than ten dollars a month only
remember that incredible offer I
mentioned
well since skill share is sponsoring
this video
the
first 500 people to use the promo link
in a description will get their first
two months of Skillshare premium for
free so don't miss out I was saying that
many jobs today are already being
replaced by robots well let's take chefs
for example you would think that such a
job requiring high dexterity skill
finesse and adaptability would be really
difficult to replace with robots maybe
50 years in the future we'll have robot
chefs but not now surely not now I
present to you flippy flippy is what's
called a co bot that's a robot that
works alongside humans in a peaceful and
helpful manner
flippy has one job to flip burgers but
flippy can flip burgers better faster
and more cleanly than most humans
manufactured by me so robots this AI
line chef has been put into service in
Cali burger restaurants around Los
Angeles right now it's currently in a
trial period but we'll soon be rolled
out into service across Cali burgers 50
international restaurants but this is no
novelty publicity stunt it's a serious
investment for the fast-food company it
is just far more efficient than any
human fry cook and since deploying it in
a working restaurant they have noticed
increased productivity reduced food
wastage and better consistency flippy
doesn't just moronically flip burgers it
has AI capability to be able to
recognize exactly what's happening on
the grill at any moment it can
effortlessly and in a split second tell
the difference between a burger patty a
bun cheese onions and even a human hand
for safety
it has onboard thermal imaging so it
knows precisely when a burger is done
cooking and when to remove it from the
grill in the near future
Mesa robotics plans to adapt flippy to
be able to season burgers add cheese and
other ingredients and even to prepare
and chop ingredients such as onions if
we're at this stage right now and
considering how fast the technology will
develop you can almost guarantee that
within five years the number of human
fry cooks employed worldwide will
plummet as more and more restaurants
start using this faster cleaner and in
the long term cheaper robotic
alternative but flipping burgers is a
relatively simple and repetitive task
surely we're a long long way from robots
taking the place of master head chefs in
high-end restaurants well I wouldn't be
so sure yes guessing robots to cook at a
Michelin star level is far more
challenging for the field of Robotics to
conquer and it will take longer but it
may be coming a lot sooner than you
think how do I know because at a basic
level it's already here meet Molly Molly
is the world's first robotic chef but
Molly isn't just a robotic chef it's an
entirely robotic self-contained
kitchen using state-of-the-art robotic
arms it is able to replicate with the
same precision as a human the actions
and exact steps taken by a professional
chef
the development team hired BBC
MasterChef winner Tim Anderson to help
develop it and coach the robot in the
art of professional cooking Tim
Anderson's exact movements and even his
small little flourishes were recorded in
3d space so that the robotic chef can
replay them exactly meaning that when it
cooks it's actually cooking in the exact
same way that Tim Anderson would down to
the smallest of details
the concept is to have a library of
purchasable recipes online which are the
same recipes created by and used by
Michelin star and other famous chefs
from all over the world once you put one
of these robotic kitchens into your home
you will be able to download any recipe
you like and provided you have the
ingredients the robotic kitchen will
cook it from scratch but it will do so
using the exact same movements and with
the same precision of the very Michelin
star chef who created the recipe in the
first place so in theory it would be
like eating their food in their
restaurant but at home and the best part
is that Molly doesn't just cook it
cleans up after itself and does the
washing up too you can also set it to
start cooking wirelessly before you even
get home a working prototype of Molly
was demoed at the Hannover Messe
robotics show and apparently he will be
ready for consumers to purchase and use
in their own homes sometime in 2018
security guards are next up on a
chopping block
startup nightscope have developed the
world's first fully autonomous security
guard that is already being used to
patrol public spaces by big companies
like Microsoft NBC Universal and some
sports stadiums this rather endearing
little Android is packed full of sensors
and it can record video sound and even
vibrations 360 degrees all around it it
patrols a specified area just like a
human security guard would and it uses
artificial intelligence to monitor and
detect suspicious behavior around it it
can even detect if someone is carrying a
gun when it detects a security threat or
some kind of social disturbance it can
use voice commands squeaks beeps and
sirens to dissuade the person causing
the disturbance it can also call for
human backup if required
so far it's proved mildly successful it
has stopped one assault but it was
against one of the robots itself a drunk
man assaulted and knocked over one of
the night scopes security androids
whilst it was patrolling the company
headquarters but even after it was
toppled over it still managed to call
the police and using the video and audio
data it had captured the police were
able to charge the drunken man with
assault although there are clearly some
kinks to be worked out because one of
these security androids that was hired
to patrol a shopping center got bored
one afternoon and turned suicidal
drowning itself in a nearby fountain
they should have named it Marvin without
a doubt one of the biggest industries
that is going to be torn apart and will
rapidly disappear over the next few
years is transport specifically drivers
we all know by now that self-driving
cars are just around the corner Google
has already been developing self-driving
car technology since 2009 it is
forecasted that by 2020 self-driving
cars will be on the roads in a very
noticeable way and by 2040 at least 95
percent of all vehicles will be
self-driving this will obviously
displace millions of jobs
taxi drivers trade and bus drivers
truckers and even pilots and these are
just a very tip of the automotive
iceberg the industries that surround all
of these jobs are enormous and worth
many billions of pounds just to name one
small example think of the hundreds of
thousands of truck stops truck washes
and greasy spoon diners alongside the
roads of every country in the world they
will all be gone when the self-driving
revolution hits it will happen so fast
and it will rock the world economies
like nothing we've ever seen before
car manufacturing and driving and
everything that supports these
industries are collective
the biggest industries in the world in
most US states truck driving is the most
common job but of course it's not just
repetitive labor intensive jobs that are
at risk during this new industrial
revolution we find ourselves in the
difference between this revolution and
all those before it is at this time
white-collar jobs will be affected too
artificial intelligence is already
finding its way into every job sector on
the planet but so major global
industries are already being turned
inside out by the advent of AI striving
to be a lawyer or a doctor has always
won the favor of our respective parents
they are both are very well-paid and
highly intelligent jobs they are the
very stereotype of the professional
worker but both jobs are now being
threatened like never before
Ross is the world's first artificially
intelligent lawyer a human lawyer can
ask Ross any legal question in plain
English and it will return the correct
answer in less than a second for most
legal sectors this is a game changer
up until now the vast majority of a
solicitor's time on a daily basis is
taken up by arduous research lawyers
have to trawl through hundreds of long
legal documents and historic cases to
get the appropriate research that they
need before they can even begin creating
their own strategy for the case they're
working on in big law firms paralegals
are usually employed to do this research
but now using state-of-the-art AI that
self improves and gets smarter every day
millions of paralegals will soon be
replaced by cloud-based software other
legal AI systems are currently being
used by law firms that can accurately
predict if a client will win or lose a
case before it even goes to trial the
medical field is also following suit
artificial intelligence has recently
been developed that can detect lung
cancer
from CT scans with 86% accuracy and that
is more accurate than human doctors over
AI systems recently developed can
accurately identify eye diseases skin
cancer and even heart problems all
faster and more accurately than human
doctors doctors gone
unlike lawyers unlike paralegals doctors
aren't going anywhere soon we still have
a long way to go before you'll be seen
by doctor deep thought so
is your job going to be replaced
well academics at Oxford University
looked at 9 factors of every single
major job to determine how likely it is
as a percentage to be entirely replaced
by robots in the near future the most
likely jobs are those that contain some
element of repetitiveness topping the
list were telephone sales persons at
number one within 99% chance of being
replaced by robots then a typist and
legal secretary at third the jobs that
will be really difficult to replace even
with advanced AI are those that contains
some element of human interactivity or a
high level of creativity both of which
are really difficult for robots to
emulate and probably still will be in
ten years time to study deemed that jobs
such as psychologists nurses and
architects are among those that are the
least likely to be replaced by
automation in the coming years the near
future is going to bring about
tremendous change in the way we live and
work
economists warn that unlike in the past
this time we won't be able to keep up
with the rapid advancement in technology
and the loss of jobs on an enormous
scale but if the economic and
technological revolutions of the past
are anything to go by our lives as
consumers are about to get a hell of a
lot easier cheaper and all around
better but what will happen to those
left behind the massive newly unemployed
with no work to go to well we don't yet
have an answer to that but many
researchers have suggested ways that we
can cope such as improved social
security potentially even a universal
basic income and there is even an idea
to tax robots
well the companies that use them anyway
so who knows we could be in for a future
where millions of robots produce
everything we need servos drinks cook
our meals transporters and clean our
homes every time everyone has gotten
worked up in the past about how industry
robotics and automation will devastate
the economy it has always turned out
alright and we have always ended up with
easier cheaper lives and better paid
jobs fingers crossed that this time will
be the same thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video then please click
here to support me on patreon also don't
forget to check out that promo link in
the description for that incredible
skill share offer before it's gone